president putin's war in ukraine
has presented us with a new strategic
reality
today
the ukrainian chief of defense
lieutenant general zalushny provided the
allied chiefs of defense with an update
on the situation
in his country
we commended ukraine for the willingness
across all generations
to fight for freedom
ukraine will never accept
russian occupation
and nato
will support ukraine for as long
as necessary
subsequently the chiefs of defense
discussed what this war means for nato's
posture in the short term and in the
long term
i want to stress
that we are not looking at the situation
in ukraine alone
together with finland and sweden and our
asia pacific partners australia
japan new zealand and the republic of
south korea
the allied chiefs of defense discussed
how we can best assess all global
security developments that affect
our alliance with uh perhaps a delay in
the
accession negotiations and possibly even
the accession of finland and sweden on
the military side what preparations do
you perhaps need to adjust if these two
countries are not going to be coming
into
um
under under nato's command do you feel
need to be adjusted not that you will
have to as nato need to be adjusted to
make sure that the these ally these
potential allies will be safe before
article 5 applies to them do you see any
dangers for them in turkey continuing to
block accession negotiations thank you
i'll just go ahead and take the first
part i i think what we all want the most
is for diplomacy
to come to the forefront
and if that conversation took place it
is my hope as a result of that
conversation we get one step closer to
achieving a diplomatic solution
with regard to finland and sweden um i
mean their accession request is is just
in
and uh
there's a normal process where the
nations are looking at
that request
and then there's a sequence of things
that need to be done
and at some stage
uh we are at the point where the nations
need time
for ratifying uh if all the nations
agree to to to those two countries to to
join
then a a time period starts where we
need to ratify
the treaty within the the 30 allied
nations and then
during that time basically it is
important that of course the two nations
have security assurances which is not
the same
as article 5 because they're not a
member yet and as we all know there's a
number of nations or groups of nations
that have basically already talked
and agreed to
assist finland and sweden and to provide
them with that assurance